kate is with us Cades in Salt Lake hi
Kade how are you I'm doing great how are
you dad
better than I deserve what's up all
right so my wife's family's on baby
steps three and I'll put you peach in
the path for vehicles you want to keep
the total amount under half of your
annual income is that correct yeah you
know why I was actually gonna ask why so
we're in a situation where we're looking
to sell one and right now we're about
we're a little over half so okay well
the rate the reason is is that cars go
down in value very very rapidly
like really like in half in no time
right they lose about sixty to seventy
percent of the value in the first four
years you own them and so you turn fifty
thousand bucks into ten thousand so fast
it makes your head swim right and so
yeah you don't you don't want to take
that kind of losses if you can't afford
to take that kind of losses now if you
make fifteen million a year and you lose
fifty grand on a car it's not a problem
but if you make fifty grand a year and
you lose twenty five thousand on a car
that's a problem yeah and so it holds
back your wealth-building when you've
got items that you own that go the other
direction that's where the principle
comes from don't own too much stuff
that's going down in value and then
wonder why you're broke so how about you
I want what are your cars worth all of
them we're on baby seven three so
everything's paid off and we have three
different vehicles we have a $20,000
truck $6,000 car and then a $3,000
little beater truck so we make about
forty one a year so why do you have a
$26,000 truck oh it's a twenty thousand
columns or a twenty dollar okay yeah and
so that's the one we're looking to sell
actually come in like this week or two
and I don't want to replace it with
something that expensive I just kinda
wanted to know why it was important to
keep it under but then would you
recommend since we're working on baby
step three we're right in the beginning
of
selling that truck would you recommend
just funding the emergency fund but that
working from there they go up in vehicle
after that yeah so um what is what do
you do for a living how do you like
landscaping construction and stuff like
that and how old are you 23
okay all right so here's the thing yeah
I would move down to about a ten
thousand dollar truck and I don't know
why you have a spare vehicle either why
do you have a spare vehicle so the spare
vehicle it's used for work as well it's
not something that we are planning on
keeping long term we just kind of had it
around to help with work a little bit
and things and so that's the beater
truck $3,000 little one all right yeah
yeah here's the thing whatever I'm if
you continue to do construction whatever
you drive on the construction side is
going to get dinged and bumped and beat
up so just decide what it is you want to
destroy do you want to destroy $7,000
truck or $70,000 wrecker and that's you
know that you're not going to get ahead
the you know the Chevy commercials for
commercials these pickups driving
through a mud puddle on a construction
site gets all these guys to buy
construction trucks that they shouldn't
have on construction sites these are
work trucks and so they you know the guy
on the construction site that has the
worst truck is the one that makes the
most money that's just a rule I had a
guy come and like brick on a project on
their house one time I swear to God the
truck wasn't worth $100 I'll bet you the
guy's a multi-millionaire he was an
artist with brick I know that and he
charged for it but yeah his truck
couldn't I mean I never saw a truck that
has so many dings on in my life the
things had the crud beat out of it and
he looked like somebody walked around
the baseball bat and it was like 48
years old I mean it was a horrible truck
and he'd just grand he just really loved
his ultra because that that's what you
want to drive on the site man so yeah
you can keep the spare vehicle for that
and then get you a driver that's not
your daily driver to the construction
site that's a little bit better and just
move down in truck that's what I would
do
just don't have money invested in things
that go down in value is you want to
build wealth put money and things to go
up in value see I did this kind of stuff
y'all so I was 23 just like you and the
car always wanted was a Jaguar so my
grandpa super conservative child of the
depression made me take nails out of a
board and straighten him out and put him
in a coffee can you know the grandpa we
all had one or we had knew somebody like
that right I mean guys saved twine you
know he saved everything and you know
when he passed away he was a
multi-millionaire and he never really
he never even invested he was scared the
stock market it was all just money he
put in the bank it was just money in the
bank he just kept putting money in the
bank and there's like a million dollars
in there you know and I remember I knew
he was frugal and I knew he had built
some wealth but anyway you know I'm 23
years old and I'm a high roller I'm a
I'm the king of the world right and so I
bought a Jaguar and I got paid thirty
thousand bucks for it this is 1982 long
time ago so I pull up in his driveway
and he goes what's that he never seen a
Jaguar thing and he goes what's that I
said that's a Jaguar and he goes really
you know would you pay for that I said
whatever it was thirty thousand $26,000
roars I paid for it he starts shaking
his head and he goes yeah that's dawn I
said what do you mean grandpa just
bought a dadgum Jaguar it'll be proud of
me look at this car man
your grandsons driving a fine automobile
here yeah I'll be proud of that he goes
I'm not proud of it you're dumb so what
do you mean he goes well what's the car
gonna be worth in five years and then I
put my money and stuff it goes up in
value son that's dumb
I drove off mad at him remember when
they just about towed that car when I
was getting going through bankruptcy and
the repo guys calling me I sold it like
one day before they repo'd it
and all I can remember is hearing my
grandpa say has dumb this is dumb I put
my money and stuff that goes up in value
son I don't put my money stuff that goes
down in value it's a good equation you
know this is the Dave Ramsey show